tenemos una ecuación que tiene
expresiones racionales así que te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trata de
descubrir por tu propia cuenta qué
valores de x satisfacen la ecuación muy
bien hagámoslo todos juntos lo primero
que me gustaría ver es si podemos
simplificar la expresión quizás no sea
factor izando los numeradores y los
denominadores y luego ver si hay
factores en común aunque bueno no sólo
vamos a poder simplificar el lado
izquierdo verdad porque el lado derecho
ya está más que simplificado entonces
veamos qué es lo que puede ocurrir con
el numerador entonces podríamos tratar
de factorizar esto es decir buscar dos
números que multiplicados nos den 21
pero suma 2 menos 10 entonces eso quizás
puede ser 3 y 7 pero para que nos dé
aquí negativo serían menos 7 y menos 3
entonces esto sería x menos 7 x
x menos 3 ahora bien el denominador
podríamos factorizar un 3 verdad
entonces tendríamos 3 que multiplica a x
menos 4 verdad entonces por ejemplo aquí
lo que podemos ver es que tenemos un en
el denominador tenemos factores x 4 en
ambos del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho entonces quizás si nos conviene
sustituir esta expresión que teníamos
por esta otra que acabamos de descubrir
verdad sin embargo aquí por ejemplo en
el numerador tendremos x menos 7 y x
menos 3 y pues yo creo que convendrá
dejarlo simplemente como habíamos
iniciado entonces vamos a eliminar esta
factorización y bueno vamos a ponerlo
como lo teníamos muy bien ahí ahí está
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar de ambos lados por x 4 para
que se puedan cancelar estos factores
entonces multiplicamos por x menos 4 del
lado derecho y multiplicamos x
- 4 vamos a multiplicar por x 4 también
del lado izquierdo entonces qué es lo
que pasa del lado izquierdo de este
factor se cancela con este otro y del
lado derecho estos factores se cancelan
verdad entonces ahora podríamos
reescribir esta expresión como x
cuadrada menos 10 x + 21 y esto va
dividido entre 3 que es el único factor
aquí que sobrevivió y del lado derecho
tendremos simplemente x menos 5 verdad x
menos 5 ahora para poder digamos
resolver esta ecuación necesitamos por
ejemplo quitar este 3 que tenemos en el
denominador así que podemos multiplicar
la expresión del lado izquierdo por 3 y
también multiplicar por 3 del lado
derecho para que la igualdad no se
altere verdad entonces lo que ocurre del
lado izquierdo es que estos se cancelan
y lo que nos queda simplemente será x
cuadrada menos
es x más 21 y del lado derecho tendremos
que multiplicar
de esta forma abordado usando la
propiedad distributiva 3 por x será 3x y
3 x menos 5 es menos 15 muy bien
entonces ahora lo que podemos ver es una
expresión cuadrática igualada aún a una
expresión digamos lineal verdad entonces
lo podríamos tratar de llevar todo a
nuestra forma estándar verdad es decir
pasar todo lo que tenemos del lado
derecho del lado izquierdo es decir
vamos a restar 3x del lado derecho y
también restamos 3x del lado izquierdo y
para cancelar este 15 vamos a sumar 15
tanto del lado derecho como del lado
izquierdo y que es lo que obtenemos
bueno del lado izquierdo vamos a tener x
cuadrada
- 13 x + 21 y 15 son 36 y esto del lado
derecho obtendremos simplemente 0
entonces ya tenemos una ecuación
cuadrática digamos en la forma estándar
verdad y lo que trataremos de hacer es
factorizar este polinomio cuadrática
verdad para ver cuáles son las
soluciones de esta ecuación entonces
pensemos en dos números que
multiplicados nos den 36 pero sumados
nos den menos 3 entonces podríamos
pensar en 4 y 9 pero para que sumados
nos dé un número negativo ambos tendrían
que ser negativos verdad entonces sería
x menos 4 por x menos 9 igual a 0 y
ahora tenemos dos números que
multiplicados nos dan 0 quiere decir que
el primer número es cero es decir x
menos 40 o bien x menos 90 en el primer
caso tendríamos que x es igual a 4
verdad simplemente sumando 4 de ambos
lados
y en el segundo caso tendremos que x es
igual a 9 sumando 9 de ambos casos
entonces estas son nuestras dos posibles
soluciones a la ecuación original verdad
y si regresamos a la ecuación original
teníamos esto acá verdad quizás valdría
la pena anotar lo aquí x es igual a 4
x es igual a 9 pero lo que podemos notar
es que hay que tener cuidado con la
solución de x igual a 4 verdad porque si
nosotros tratamos de sustituir en esta
ecuación original vamos a tener x menos
cuatro verdad este factor de aquí se
anula cuando x es igual a 4 pero está en
el denominador entonces estaríamos
esencialmente dividiendo entre 0 tanto
del lado izquierdo como del lado derecho
y eso no puede ser verdad
tenemos que tener entonces cuidado con
esta solución eso quiere decir de hecho
que no puede ser válida la solución para
esto
ecuación así que esta no es válida y por
lo tanto la única solución válida sería
x igual a 9